in previous episode
[Music]
you responsible Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
how's it going Brad my name is Paris
welcome back are those [ __ ]
disgusting [ __ ]
oh god damn it this is not good
come on better oh [ __ ]
hi Bella what are you doing
I hate those
it's so [ __ ] disturbing are we gonna
play us them no again we are playing
playing I'll come back to siren blood
guys we're gonna play as Melissa Gale
it's 5:00 in the morning we're gonna
help Bella our daughter escape this is
gonna be [ __ ] terrible she gonna get
him that state again cuz she bit the
zombie and everyone kid she's been to
zombie he's gonna be infected I don't
know if you'll get infected for an
inviting egg all right we need to find a
weapon we need to reach the east fields
ah son of a beyotch
well this is the church that we arrived
in the other time and oh [ __ ]
never mind we're not going there all
right we'll go over here oh it's not a
scarecrow
that sounds wonderful not scared it's
just a bad weather everything is fine I
wish I had chocolate right now you know
chocolate helps helps the mood but get
out of my back
Bella shake your ass somewhere else
Bella thank you
alright we jumped up is that what I
think it is it do thing alright we got a
weapon that's the biggest issue in all
these games finding a [ __ ] gun
I mean weapon alright we cross the
bridge then we hit these boys oh well
what are you doing oh it hurts
run Bella [ __ ] crazy people trying to
shoot me in [ __ ] well I Rana don't get
shot bow alright you can't shoot us man
son of a [ __ ] where the hell is he who
the prize multi comfy okay we're just
we're almost there we can just keep
running for him keep it low Bella you
below ah [ __ ]
this one down there shut the [ __ ] up
okay so we go which way the lipid dated
shed I have never heard that word in my
entire life that's the way out I will
write [ __ ] nightmare
haha I miss oh [ __ ] nice going sir
anyone else
oh [ __ ] there is oh they're coming
behind us hello woman you have no eyes
wait to do give me your eyes I slap I
finish her you see that Bella well I
hate people and that's why we kill them
you have something in here perhaps nope
well it was an adventure bad luck come
over here come to mama Bella that's a
good girl
that's a good girl back we have now
reached the east fields and our next
objective is to go to the west field
all right Bella keep it [ __ ] cool
alright no I hate this place and no
[ __ ] sick of Yara and your [ __ ]
alright they're worshiping that tree
it's kind of [ __ ] disturbing
Bella if they see your ass I'm gonna
kill you why do they worship that tree
it's so [ __ ] creepy
we gotta sneak past these [ __ ]
shut up Bella whoo
[ __ ] hate them what do you want don't
touch Bella if she dies I die this
weapon is awesome hello thank you shut
your mouth you will love this place
Olivia have you done all right we are
stupid we need to go out here I like
that the reuse environment for different
characters I don't know I hate when
games just kind of become linear I mean
some might say it's because you know
they're [ __ ] lazy but I don't think
so I think it's more because I don't
know I like it all right just what
Mesnick yeah hello hello welcome to my
nipple custom boogeyman
that's me boogey woman's [ __ ] nice
mirror bro
oh this is bhakta moment nice mirror let
me just finish you off
thank you I kill your woman
what how do you know it come up here kya
slice it to that that s it doesn't work
right
are you serious is still alive hey down
[ __ ]
alright if I had a penis I would keep a
gear or balls for that matter all right
so let's feel all right just chill out
my would you shut up Oh a graveyard
wonderful
all right I don't see any one of them
watch what was that
I can't leave Bella ballet throwed the
mat [ __ ] don't worry honey
mommy's gonna protect you how how how
how
if someone tell me how okay knock over
the old drum oh I don't like that I do
not like this hello there hello there
what's your name okay
so by yelling I attract that
[ __ ] but oh [ __ ] don't counted
playful I have no interest in being
killed times you knock them all [ __ ]
over
[Music]
just saying hey that's enough for you
all right I did it whoa whoa holy [ __ ]
no yeah I don't you know what let's go
down there use the lighter oh my god are
you gonna sacrifice yourself oh it's so
ugly
Oh stupid [ __ ] I got it Bobby dagen oh
my god this game is just so fun
ah okay Mellie sighs dad now please
please be alright we're not all right oh
yeah that is gonna cry
oh no it's glasses looks like I have to
buy a new pair after all that's one less
thing for her to be mad about
oh I wanted them to stay together what's
this that's a charging one yes you have
you have done this before
shoot em come on look you endure this
review come on man die Oh No
PewDiePie Japanese alright so we just
press C I go which is always nice
because he had a gun
how Bela Monroe escaped and acquired
Asians right say Bella from the shabiha
alright
that is not how you say hi Bella are you
I know you consuming [ __ ] on me
but I guess I don't have to just die
place there we go and then while flying
[ __ ] I hate the plane
ah [ __ ] sake there we go hey this for
fun we go him I guess Bella the [ __ ] is
she up again stay down thank you where's
Bella now
I guess I gotta dig on knowledge to save
that [ __ ]
[Applause]
help Bella escape from the Carina noodle
shop but I love noodles I don't like
them I don't punch
air-air did nothing crazy [ __ ] there's
many of them I can't even find her all
right
abdomens nice add nice Asian
I'm a last time I made a remark about
how shorty was and everyone was like
rage - yo is rage says oh my god I can't
believe that agent people are not short
right Bella I think you hello hi I'm
trying to help you [ __ ] come on don't
be force fun
it will only hide your let up come back
here
mommy is dad I'm your worst nightmare
now come on
[ __ ] like I'm I can't
[Applause]
from the fly Savita they're butterflies
you do not like
oh hello oh [ __ ]
there we go right Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
stay away from her thank God Jesus
Christ will you please [ __ ] stop
running from a I'm not your mommy but I
have chest been boob man boobs are
underrated you know hello thank you
[Applause]
where the [ __ ] no not now I have to kill
everyone like a [ __ ] bad-ass find the
worship Hall Korea what I quiet ancient
back where that Lebel ago what about
Bella well well I guess it's in the
temple I am Not sure I do not want to
switch my [ __ ]
[Music]
it's locked and you don't have the key I
guess I hadn't need the key then alright
so looking at the map it should supposed
to be over here I just hope I can find
it it seems kind of trick hell out
headshot [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
ba ba ba ba yes bah bah bah bah bah bah
I can't watch
I'm on the ropes [ __ ] I'm on a
rope leap of faith
yeah Wow Fonz god damn it not funny not
funny
shut up oh no oh no baby I do not want
to go now
now is that the time [ __ ] now it's not
the time now it's not the time
yes now it's not you papa now it's not
that [ __ ] many are there well we got
to do that [ __ ] again
stay down please what a wonderful way to
die I wish I am so lucky or next time I
mean when I acted I all right
you know get out leap of faith time
[ __ ] do not go down there whatever
you do all right it's got to be another
[ __ ] way
[Music]
I mean any [ __ ] human being can go
past thank you
I'd be little disappointed otherwise all
right let's see what we got oh it should
be here somewhere
[Music]
can we fire what in the [ __ ] sakes [ __ ]
inside No
[Applause]
[Music]
okay well we have the cold let's jump
down bro it's gonna be fine just dump
down well be a [ __ ] acrobat then why
see if I care
oh wow aren't we all impressed by our
acrobatic skills all right what if you
die now and we have to do all that [ __ ]
again how about that all right let's
just be swift and gentle just like I'm
sorry it's your worst [ __ ] nightmare
I always say that but poor guy I just
want to chill with some [ __ ] some
moussaka drinking beer we could have
easily [ __ ] broken open that door
what's our next goal find the worship
policy acquired ancient book arias
ancient but I heard this weird edit
weird an address awesome
okay we got the ancient book strange
tales of goo jackal and it's a very
archive that's interesting mission
accomplished yes this game keeps deliver
keeps on delivering a [ __ ] awesome
episode I love this chapter let's see
what we get for the as our avoid we get
a movie
oh so that's how it became immortal she
sacrificed her blood for him I thought
it was because he watched this is my
blood and pack of salvation so so that
that happened before earlier in the game
we were on tended bonanza
[Music]
so that's how all right or is it really
was all foreseen it was all very there
draught watching this really
[Music]
Oh what the [ __ ] have you guys heard
about the news yeah this is terrible in
the Kim Kardashian's I hacked up I'm
much prettier cific oh oh oh [ __ ]
good job Bella oh that's creepy I love
this guy so much it's [ __ ] awesome
all right press can't wait before to
play episode 10 like a braided you
enjoyed this guy color red today and
I'll see you next episode over I may not
be read well only hard July
[Music]
yeah I'm in luck
ah
oh this is disturbing
I'm fabulous